it was an honor to be at the microphone
for that I've done combines for 14 years
and that is easily one of the top five
moments in the history of covering the
combine when she came Griffin stepped
out there a man of for 3/8 topped only
perhaps by the 20 reps of 225 and the
weight and reps from the day before from
UCF Shekinah Griffin here on the Rich
Eisen show how you doing chicken thanks
for having today come on now I saw you
just a few hours after you put the 20 up
you know we were you at the Michael
Johnson performance suite I was the
other athlete in the room at the time
and it just seemed like you were you
stuff was dawning upon you at that
moment in time that that that that the
significance outside of the weight and
reps room by the rest of planet Earth
was becoming apparent to you well what
was going through your your skull at
that point
Shiki I mean at that point was I was
just feeling like you know everything
was was that a good start but I don't
remember Dan he knows only a beginning
of what I want to accomplish from that
we came in you know that's why I want to
measure
njp we both nation it was again some
good treatment and make sure that we
stay focused on the task at hand
yeah that thing that we did well that
for the most part it was just making
sure that you know and I got the bench
press out the way make sure I get there
make sure that I was able to finish
strong throughout the entire weekend and
you know I think you remember the you
know I showed you the the tweet of the
mom with a seven-year-old kid who drew
you right withdrew your yeah yeah and
what you think of when you saw that that
was awesome to be able to see that and
you know the John's it was really
accurate so that was I was pretty cool I
was really cool I was excited to see
their and they'll give it a see me and
see that picture come right after I mean
that was amazing and it felt so good to
be able to see that and I mean it maybe
it made me feel happy and you're so
happy definitely do you view yourself as
an inspirational figure
yeah I mean at this time I'm starting to
I'm starting to figure out you know what
I'm able to do for other people
I mean you know I talked to my mom a
month ago about it and I didn't feel I
didn't have that feeling but now I'm
starting to understand more as I go as
you get as I go on more I'm sort
understanding what I'm able to do him
and maybe feel so good where you have so
many people behind you and supporting
you knowing that you're doing the right
thing and you know obviously be doing
what I need to do to be able to you know
accomplish my goals but not only
articles for me but there's only one say
example for those who outside looking in
and I think that's important for me
because you know nowadays you got so
many people who want to know have a
say-so on things and be able to set
limitations on people and which is which
is never accurate because you can't
nobody ever set limitations for you
besides yourself and I want to be able
to be a figure where you know I can stop
people from doing it because people said
something limitations on me but I don't
think I'm being them all right now I
would say that I mean what so what did
your mom tell you about that
responsibility walk me through that
conversation a little bit more you know
mine I mean for me my mom we are talking
about you know just being able to this
being able to overcome so many things
and not be overwhelmed with everything
for the most part and pain comes home
fast and some people do overwhelming and
not being able to withstand it but I
think you know having my family around
me having them be able to talk to you
have been being able to be open to them
about everything that's happening it
never gets report was overwhelming to
the point where I can do it and I think
that's pretty good because you know
obviously if someone's going on but
being able to sort stand and be able to
feed our figure fair but I'm looking
there I mean if they're so good that do
that because I know if I can keep going
I'm doing is only gonna help kids and
make sure you like know what I want to
be able to do this I want to be able to
converse or swim you know Marcos I want
to be able to you know never let nobody
tell me what I can't do I want to be
able to defeat at that guy girl it'll
just be the best and everything and
everything they do she came Griffin here
on the Rich Eisen show did you get that
sense from any in the scouting community
any in the interview room any and all
that
general sense is that there will be some
people in the NFL who just automatically
think you can't based on just judging
you by by your your left arm yeah I mean
I know it I mean everything was level
yeah I've been only been a few coaches
or somebody who feel like you know what
the founders guys is capable of doing
anything but you know that's what I do
what I do and I make sure I can prove
people wrong every single time I'm ever
gonna stop doing it and you were
cramping up during that that workout as
I saw on Sunday did you think at any
point in time it may be that that your
pro day would be a better shot for you
to work out as opposed to the combine I
mean I got to the second one
I thought it creping that really bad but
you know I want to prove and even though
cramping the drug I think I was it was
you know accomplish a lot of that but
you know I definitely want to be ready
for the pro day and show what I can
really do with a hundred percent I mean
I think it's gonna be a real sight to
see so I just want to talk to you about
do you remember the store do you
remember the story that people have
heard about again you know what learning
your story about your mom catching you
to try and cut your fingers that you did
have on your left hand off does that
doesn't do you recall that at all that
you were trying as a young man to to do
what was eventually surgically necessary
yeah when I was my dad I think you know
it's pretty serious I mean a little
unjustly being rolled over here in my
hand I sprained you know I know I'm
going to the kitchen and I'm gonna I'm
gonna do what I need to do for me to
feel better I was crying on the counter
getting my brother John trying to remove
my old fingers trying to be you know dr.
Griffin but my mom caught me and the
next day you know marching into the
hospital a large number of jacking my
reg ragging she picked me up
you know is a veal down on the on the
bed I'm over they put the mask on me and
I woke up with bandages
and then do you remember what the next
few years was like no I mean football
player I want you to tell you up the
advantages over the next video I'm
outside touching the wall came down
it came back in the house with for the
bloody bandage but it felt so much
better than what it was before they
didn't matter that I had a little bit of
my family's I was good to go and then
actually knows so much I'm I'm in
organized football and I never stopped
sitting there Dion was your guy right
growing up without here's your Idol
prime yeah he's amazing he's amazing and
I don't know I had to get my you know my
pile time when I took off running that
was neat for us at the NFL Network to
hook the two of you up on live TV
yesterday I mean it was I had to how to
control my emotions in that dr. house it
you know be able to sleep clearly around
me and being able to get a good
conversation I mean I was amazed I mean
I would never I would never thought any
is our opportunity today feels good that
I was able to well a couple more
questions for you Shekinah Griffin here
in the Rich Eisen show who interviewed
you what interview rooms did you go into
what teams did you talk to at the
combine I mean I did a lot of informants
but I didn't want any of you with with
Seattle that's all you know I really
enjoy I really enjoyed it
being able to be here but I try to Pete
Carroll and I were talking them and I
wasn't like you know what's fast and he
was like you know for long backer you
know for six four five all right now
let's fast it was saying like no no you
make sure you I'm going to be give my
brother time you know you think about
you talking to a man be good huh no you
can keep it so so close like yeah I know
you're go for four to nine for three
deadly
ergo well you got the gold so I assume
but is that the goal is to hear your
name on draft art being drafted by
Seattle so you play with your brother
again I mean I mean needs being in
Seattle with my brother will be amazing
you know that would be one heck of a
story I can tell you that but me having
an opportunity is the main goal and I
ever want opportunity now your
opportunity to show somebody what I can
do I'll make sure I get the job done
well she came you sure did man and you
know I appreciate you calling in here
and you're welcome here anytime I'd love
to keep in touch with you to follow you
along your journey and when you hear
name on draft night I will be standing
given the ovation that you deserve in
Dallas thank you always
you got it thanks again that says she
king Griffin the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience